they were wrong about the death totals
fatality rates they were wrong about
masks they were wrong about ventilators
they were wrong about the curve they
were wrong about social just about
social distancing changing the curve
whereas if the actual change occurred
before social distancing they were wrong
about economic impact they have been
wrong about ever rethink what does it
mean trust experts and how do you pick
which experts has this pandemic changed
your faith in some institutions now that
institution could be the who though we
would not advise that you should trust
everything who says in the corner of
ours cannot be transmitted from human
contact and it was created by the
Marines in Avatar so nothing would say
would go against the who but let me let
me just be really clear about this this
right now in the face of overwhelming
data is one of the greatest hood wings
ever in the American public as far as a
Power Grip as far as the transition from
laws or protocols that would be
appropriate initially without data which
we all understood we all got on board
with the American society's good nature
has been preyed upon now and it is at a
point I think most Americans are fed up
we see this in the polls and it's tough
depending on how you read which polls
depending which question they ask they
do you want to go back to work
are you concerned about kovetz like
seventy percent say they want to go back
to work but then know certain say
they're still concerned about comedy hey
count me among them yeah exactly
I manipulate the data all you want but
let me just let's just do I want to know
where do you guys wind up you can chat
with us too with the experts in Khamenei
well let me be really clear when I say
that the experts were wrong um the
experts were wrong on death total deaths
death rates infection rates masks
ventilators testing economic impact what
else non locked out states reopening and
how that had a total search they have
been wrong about absolutely everything
that would be of consequence let's be
really clear here to buy their own
argument right they said hey listen a
two million dead in the United States
which we now know is a flawed model
right we talked about Niall Ferguson who
violated his own lockdown knows mr.
Ferguson you're violating your rule name
that movie line you violated the own
lockdown orders two million dead is what
they said two million dead unless you
get to work mr. president and President
Trump took took them at face value okay
all right two billion dead it's time to
get to work
less than 5% of that we're less than 5%
of that how is that not a resounding
success an overwhelming victory unless
you experts were in fact wrong you have
to pick one or the other was it going to
be 2 million deaths and it was reduced
by 95 percent or were you wrong in your
predictions it hasn't you can't be right
the whole way just like President Trump
can't be right the whole way and I was
interesting when people say Donald
Trump's side well what's that what side
is he really on he was the guy who went
out and advised lockdowns he was a guy
who went out in advise mask he was the
one who supported today's he was one who
got mental it was a list of the private
industry right and then he said ok now
it's time to get back to work you can't
say that he's consistently been on one
side here he was on the side of all
Americans which is let's stop let's
pause until we know more we know more
and unfortunately for the experts we
know that you've been verifiably wrong
now it's okay to be wrong it is okay to
be wrong I think if nothing else this
kinds of it kind of shows us there's no
sense there is no such thing as settled
science by the very nature of what
science is especially when you're
talking about science and a pandemic
with a virus that mutates we don't even
have a cure treatment that's approved or
a vaccine yet there can be no settled
science and I'll get to some specifics
but I think it's important to understand
the difference here between science the
scientific method the scientific process
and scientism what do I mean by that
this idea that if you simply apply the
scientific method you will fix all of
society's problems listen experts should
be pulled into an advisory role and
board of a group of different experts
and by the way also include nine experts
also include everyday Americans will be
impacted by this not red-eye these rules
no not a grete at least someone who is
paid taxes and hasn't professed to be
autistic how are we not applying the
scientific method to calling [ __ ] on
China yeah well on a second but we know
about the virus if special if we don't
jump on it quickly and we know how it
spreads in urban areas or areas with
elderly populations you don't see the
same patterns that you see everywhere
else in China what do I mean by that
some of the observable patterns things
that are irrefutable now I don't mean
settled science as far as a cure but
as far as we know that this threatens
the lives of the elderly and the sick
far more significantly we know that
spreads in urban areas obviously the
only place where we don't see this
consistency of data is China where they
admitted by the way to destroying
samples in the lab remember the death
predictions were 2.2 million of course
we're not even close to that the CDC
said don't wear masks then of course
they reverse that we said early on that
a mask was good especially if you had
the sniffles testing they said with a
tear we were terrible at testings were
number one in the world of testings by
the way I love it when they say we have
more cases and more deaths than anywhere
else in the world but we put the test we
don't have more testing per capita use
the same they also said that lockdowns
as long as a full year for a vaccine
that we would be able to ride this out
most Americans now are saying they're
not able to write it out and of course
that resulted in over 36 million jobs
and unemployment as high as 40 percent
in some states or as they know Troy
Tuesday so trillions of dollars in
stimulus money I just want to be clear
that all of these things they were
incorrect
they were incorrect now at what point do
you cease being an expert if you stake
your claim and it is false not oh maybe
it could have gone either way I mean if
these people were in charge of the Vegas
betting odds we'd clean up of course
hospitals the hospitals were never
overrun thing you could say that's
because of the isolation sharing that
comes with other ramifications that
we'll talk about in a second but they're
less than normal they're empty they've
had to furlough and layoff tons o money
on Boise fault I also do wonder because
I have have a lot of relatives and
friends who work in the health care
industry and half of them at first we're
saying this is a terrible disaster we
need it now half of them are saying we
want to go back to work but they're
still half of them they say no you just
don't understand how bad it is and I've
asked them I've said one second not true
you're not working there you go yeah I
said have you seen any cases no we we
had two in our Hospital what happened
well really it wasn't it was they just
they were fine we said to keep him on
watch and that was it and I know how do
you still buy into this ago we know
because we trust the CDC go on a second
what have you observed because every
single business is anecdotal and since
these are relatives and friends but the
overwhelming data shows us that
hospitals were not overrun so again they
were wrong about death totals fatality
rates they were wrong about masks they
were wrong about ventilators they were
wrong about the curve they were wrong
about social just about social
distancing changing the curve whereas if
the actual change occurred before so
distancing they were wrong about
economic impact they have been wrong
about ever rethink there is some data
now to suggest that lockdowns actually
spread it more because in New York it
was over 80% of people who caught it
caught it at home
the remained of course then you also add
in nursing homes in the mix in the
remainder it was public transit because
of the subways right and then all others
and we do see more people makes it worse
I don't make it worse here's how I can
make it worse because a lot of people
what they're finding now may have it in
their home in most homes what's the
average number of people that go to home
even if there isn't a lot done right
yeah but they're staying in their house
getting out in the fresh open air
they're not getting out so they're
staying and basically incubating and
then a lot of them are afraid to go into
the hospital for other conditions so
they're saying now that the there's a
rise in comorbidities and people who are
staying home where covin might have been
sort of inconsequential but they go and
get something else fixed so like the
mold example right like people are like
well they would normally spend as much
time in their home in the homes
naturally have an amount of mold a out
when you live in New York and a lot of
those places are not kept up in the way
they should so if you're spending a lot
more time at home you're getting well
sure that makes sense yeah and UNICEF is
actually estimated that the lock downs
will kill more children than yeah of
course a virus will be gross in most
countries they're not leaving to go they
can't leave without documentation Wow
their houses of documentation they can't
get treated for pneumonia they can write
they can't go get riled birth elsewhere
they have to stay in their homes and
it's pretty tough to explain to those
entitled fascists in Mozambique about
supply-side economics instead they just
die thanks leftists this video subscribe
or hit the notification bell because
that lets your mobile device do people
still say cell I don't think they say
but no one says LTE we should say
cellular but we don't say LTE but then
what was there was there is roaming do
we still have roaming I think we still
have roaming if you're watching this on
mobile I've wasted a ton of your and
you're likely driving you're probably
dead
everybody's looking back now and the
road is just there are some lights and
sirens going off maybe there's like a
pair of slacks in your the grill of your
car next to the Rudolph nose that you
put in for some holiday festivity only
now it's covered in someone else's blood
so hit the notification bell join mug
Club bit lighter with credit calm / mug
Club because that's how we support this
we don't actually make any money off of
youtube and we do a full dailies like
80% more content and you know what I
hope that your blood type is o-negative